in our series three meals we travel to
different states to break bread with
boaters and hear what's on their minds
the 2020 presidential campaign marks a
big milestone for the state of New
Hampshire it's the 100th year the first
presidential primary will be held there
CBS News contributor Steve Inskeep of
NPR's Morning Edition and up first
podcast across the state to see what
voters are thinking Steve what they tell
you hey good morning we wanted an
unfiltered look at the states so we
bypassed campaign events didn't see a
single one of the candidates who flood
New Hampshire this time of year and took
a road trip we stopped for breakfast
lunch and dinner and whoever we met is
who you will meet now starting in Gorham
New Hampshire this town
[Music]
in New Hampshire's White Mountains is
home to Welsh's restaurant
[Music]
Vicki bird is a waitress
are you a lifelong resident around how
does one raise and Richard Wallingford
eats on his way to work in his interior
design store we've had good times we've
had bad times is this a good time or a
bad time
hey we're peeking the top honestly
there's not enough people to work right
now uh-huh
I mean people are coming and going you
can't get help statewide unemployment is
two-and-a-half percent and yet look at
the news this morning when we visited
news was spreading of an attack on oil
facilities in Saudi Arabia that will
affect us you know so it's just I feel
like we're on the edge of a war and it
it is pretty it's pretty scary right now
do you worry about the trade war at all
how it might affect you it has a lot of
materials are very difficult to get the
prices have increased tremendously
after breakfast we've headed southward
through the White Mountain National
Forest which feels so remote but as we
heard from the shopkeepers selling
products from China it is connected to
the global economy some of the rules of
the global financial system were made
here at the Mount Washington Hotel at a
conference back in 1944 this is the
system that has lasted ever since and
that's being challenged in these days of
trade Wars and nationalism
[Music]
here in Manchester New Hampshire these
old mill buildings which once made the
city a world leader in textiles have now
filled with more modern global
industries and when people get a chance
to take lunch they might go to Casey's
rib Shak barbecue which is our next stop
[Music]
it's baked beans Lynn Murphy is an
artist who reshapes old pieces of
furniture so you might take my busted
dresser and turn it into a work of art
absolutely she gets health benefits
through her husband Shannon who works
for a defense contractor without a doubt
I myself have forgone medical care when
I needed it because of the expense of it
do you want the government to do
something about that I I want the
government to do something about that
but I do not want socialized medicine so
when you hear dem economy started when
you hear Democrats say Medicare for all
you think no I think it's a bad idea I
really think it's a bad idea this is a
Republican family Lynn Sun kyun supports
the Republican presidents crackdown on
illegal immigration yet he feels it's
gone too far the ones who are getting
caught there they are getting thrown in
cages
towards Portsmouth we have come a long
way in this small state from the White
Mountains down to the coastal plains
where we're heading for Portsmouth this
state's traditional opening to the wider
world
[Music]
tourists mix with locals at the River
House Democrats Lynne Mallory no and Kim
Bulls are ready to vote for anyone but
the president could have a four-year
mistake but eight years is a pattern and
they've been talking through the
alternatives well if it were Biden and
one would think that's a really good
ticket
oh boy man Biden or Warren I know I
would you vote for either I'm not sure
yet I know she's not sure about
Elizabeth Warren because Warren endorsed
Medicare for all
she's Medicare for all but she doesn't
believe in keeping the private insurance
I better check that back I know you
better take that back why you don't
agree with that I don't I think a boat
somehow they got to work it out some
people keep their insurance I can take
away from you
and expect them to vote for her you just
can't she's got it back off that as you
can hear these Democrats are trying to
pick a winner and desperate to do you
may have noticed whether their leading
rider leaning ref left people know that
times are good in New Hampshire but
they're really worried about time so
interesting with two and a half percent
unemployment statewide you still got
that much discontent a lot of anxiety
about the future it's also interesting
that with health care people want the
government to do something but don't
call it socialism which is really common
that's what makes that issue so tricky
for any politician there the process how
people go about making up their minds
yeah and what matters to them and what
resonates and what doesn't yeah they
have their practical problems in their
lives but also their ideology and with
that woman in the middle that's in a
little bit of conflict she wants help
with health care doesn't want the
government to do too much and the guy
said we need a president that doesn't
tweet I thought that was interesting to
be banned yeah so he said yeah I heard
him Steve thank you